[Music]
this common brimstone is living in the
best possible location the safe leafy
garden of butterfly researcher Mateus
knows out in the fields the likelihood
of a premature death would be far higher
of the 125 species of butterfly
documented here in the state of Saxony
sixteen have disappeared along with many
other insects that's very bad news
everything we eat that's a major source
of vitamins it depends on insects as
pollinators so without pollinators no
food wells there are foods that don't
depend on pollination like meat grains
and rice but they aren't full of
vitamins in some parts of Germany insect
populations have declined by up to 80%
and that means food for many birds and
other insectivores has grown scarce
farming's become very intensive habitats
have disappeared fertilizers are used
that are bad for insects and then there
are the pesticides the aim is to squeeze
as much yield as possible out of the
soil the head of the Regional Farmers
Association tells me agriculture in
Germany is focused on maximizing
efficiency and dismisses concerns over
insects in my opinion it's rubbish the
numbers of many species are always going
up and down that's true of insects and
it's also true of mammals
if those variations and populations are
used to target certain groups of people
in certain professions I see that as
shabby treatment for mind if I click
share wish to find out what scientists
think about the issue I went to the
Helmholtz Centre for environmental
research and Leipzig to talk to
biologists Yusuf settler he's on the
UN's intergovernmental science policy
platform on biodiversity and ecosystem
services he confirms that
insect populations in Germany have
declined sharply it has a lot to do with
land usage farming the way we use the
land and particularly with the spread of
monocultures plus the use of fertilizers
and pesticides which are of course
important for farming farmers aren't
trying to destroy the land or
environment they depend on to the
contrary two-thirds of the 100 most
important crops are pollinated by bees
butterflies or flies Matthias Lewis says
that means farmers themselves ought to
be in favor of reforming farming
practices he has a collection of
specimens of butterfly species that can
no longer be found in the area this is a
process we have to stop there are very
good reasons for Germany to have a
policy that promotes biodiversity the
goal is to stop any more species
becoming extinct here by 2020 and even
to reverse the trend but we're further
from that goal than ever his collection
contains specimens of the Danube clouded
yellow that used to be lots of them in
Germany and Austria but the insects
habitats have been destroyed in those
countries and now they're all gone